I understand that video game movies are
profitable these days but I can't
believe they went for Minesweeper the
movie begins with tug a military medic
enjoying a swim near the kajaki dam in
Afghanistan suddenly an explosion
startles them and he immediately gets
out of the water then he confronts two
local boys one of whom is holding a
rifle but they just mock him tug tries
to reason with them about the dangers of
carrying guns and firing
indiscriminately but they pay no
attention to his words soon his
colleagues arrive and advise him not to
create trouble with the locals unless
he's prepared for the consequences they
suggest he put on some clothes and move
on in an effort to make peace they ask
the boys for some fish and surprisingly
they've managed to get some later a
British Chinook helicopter carrying
soldiers flies over the kajaki dam in
helmond Province it lands near other
British soldiers who quickly load
supplies and prepare for their mission
following this newcomers Prosser and
Jonesy driving military truck to deliver
a package to their base along the way
they spot fellow soldiers Jay tug and
Mark walking and offer them a ride but
playfully drive off before the trio can
join them as they arrive at their
Barracks the sergeant warmly welcomes
them and helps unload the truck with
packages Mark introduces himself to
Jonesy and they exchange short greetings
and handshakes inside the barracks the
soldiers sort through their belongings
before heading to their posts Jay a
senior officer takes Jonesy on a tour
showing him the barracks the Medics area
and the themed store Jay also reveals
that there are around 16 of them
stationed there meanwhile tug being the
only Medic in the group checks a medical
issue and Jonesy's lower body and in
return receives three cans of fruit
salad toss a salad get a salad tug
provides Jonesy with antibiotics and
anti-inflammatory medication advising
him to take them regularly as night
falls Two Soldiers inspect their
surroundings decide to keep watch
Unfortunately they spot enemy activity
at a nearby petrol station and prepare
for an attack as the enemy's group
practices firing the duo suspects them
to be part of the Taliban terrorist
group one of the soldiers named Jarhead
quickly wakes up their senior Hale as
theirs ongoing activity at the petrol
station without wasting any time Hale
joins them and watches through the
binoculars to locate the Taliban group
he tries to contact their comrades using
the radio but receives no response left
with no options he takes the risk and
fires an emergency shot to alert them
Hale then requests the Third Battalion
for air support but unfortunately their
missile doesn't hit the target and the
terrorists quickly run away the next
morning another officer Pearson spots
Taliban through his binoculars where a
vehicle is being forcefully stopped by
them Hale suspects that it is an illegal
checkpoint where terrorists are
extorting money from civilians perhaps
the same activity was being carried out
last night meanwhile the platoon from
the Third Battalion is exercising
together preparing for their upcoming
Expedition some are following routines
While others are playing around tog and
Jay entertain themselves by playing
chess using water bottles next Jarhead
hail and fast get ready to head out and
investigate the area where the Taliban
is set up a roadblock their plan is to
disarm and disperse the roadblock the
group then loads their bags with
essential supplies and sets off on their
exploration meanwhile Jay and the rest
of the team relax in their Barracks upon
reaching a specific location the group
splits up to carefully inspect their
surroundings they step forward
cautiously wary of potential traps
suddenly there's a massive explosion
when hail triggers a landmine and gets
Blown Away the explosion severely
injures them taking off part of his leg
and some fingers panicked Jarhead rushes
to hail's side trying to calm him down
the latter is in great pain and his
friends quickly try to stop the bleeding
realizing that hail may die with out
proper medical support Jarhead calls for
an emergency response through the radio
he then instructs Faz to go back and to
call for backup on the other hand
Pearson and the platoon hear the
explosion and try to contact Jarhead but
receive no response concerned Pearson
and two others prepare to go and check
on their mates similarly a mile away
Mark also hears the explosion and orders
the rest of the Third Battalion to look
for their team they gather essential
tools and rush to the location of the
Mind strike to provide assistance
despite the imminent danger the soldiers
remain determined to patrol the Steep
Hill Pearson encounters the rushing fast
who calls for backup and informs them of
the situation below upon hearing this
Pearson urgently gathers the remaining
soldiers and they make their way to help
hail meanwhile a senior officer John
arrives in his car and halts the rushing
soldiers offering them a ride to the
mine strike location arriving at the
Steep Hill they are shocked by Hale's
severe injuries wasting no time smudge
promptly attends to Hale's wounded leg
while Pearson tries to distract him from
the pain as all of this is happening
hail abruptly asks smudge to check if
his wiener still works the latter jokes
lightening the mood and informing him
that he can still play with his little
toy weird phrasing after a while Jay
arrives and informs the group that Mark
and his team have organized a rescue
party he also applies another tourniquet
to Hale's leg causing him to cry out in
pain in the next scene Mark and tug
arrive with a stretcher to transfer hail
to a safer area tog administers more
morphine to ease Hale's pain and
instructs others to Mark the dosage Mark
then assigns tasks to the other soldiers
to transport hail to a safer Place
following this they all begin marking
points on the ground making a safe route
to prevent any future explosions as the
team carefully attends to Hale's needs
adjusting his posture and providing
support to carry him to another place a
soldier suddenly shouts that there is
something hard in the ground and it's
not Hale's weiner fortunately it turns
out to be just a rock bringing relief to
everyone Hale then requests a cigarette
from tug and the rest of the patrol
group clear the area to create a safe
landing spot for the incoming rescue
helicopter somehow the group manages to
carry Hail to The Landing site they'd
prepared and after receiving a radio
message about the confirmation of the
arriving help Mark orders his men to
leave and return to their quarters
meanwhile as Pearson walks back to his
Pals he accidentally triggers another
landmine the explosion injures him
severely wounding both of his legs he
yells in pain and pleads for help but
the others can't risk approaching him
due to the danger of another explosion
however Mark and Two Soldiers cannot see
Pearson's suffering so they act quickly
and reach him they apply a tourniquet to
stop the bleeding and also inject him
with a dosage of morphine to alleviate
his pain moments later help finally
arrives but it isn't the one that they
are seeking a Chinook helicopter
approaches to land a few meters away
from their location the so soldiers know
that it is dangerous to land such a huge
helicopter there so they signal the
pilot to fly away the dust blast makes
it very difficult for the soldiers to
breathe and contact the pilot but in the
end the latter finally gets the message
and flies away unfortunately the
helicopter's downdraft is so strong that
it triggers another mine injuring Mark
with deep injuries on his arm face and
chest the soldiers cry out in agony
realizing that they are in deep trouble
Prosser is also one of those injured but
not severely he bandages himself and
despite other soldiers asking him not to
move he cannot oversee Mark's severe
condition and approaches him for help
Mark has been seriously wounded under
his shoulder and is losing a lot of
blood to stop the blood flow Prosser
takes out some gun straps and begins
wrapping it around the wound he also
gives a dose of morphine to Mark and
suggests he keep calm and hold on to his
breath on the other hand the only medic
of the group tug can't bear to see Mark
suffer and decides to rush to a side
other soldiers try to stop him as they
fear he might set off another mine
increasing the risk to all of them but
tug ignores their warning grabs his bag
and begins throwing it on the ground
before jumping on it expecting an
explosion That Never Comes despite Mark
needing immediate attention tug is
carefully making his way to him
seemingly regretting his sudden decision
to risk his own life meanwhile another
injured Soldier Harvey asks Jarhead to
intubate him as his right lung feels
like it's collapsing Harvey explains
that he is having difficulty in
breathing and that the procedure is
vital to save his life he also instructs
Jarhead to insert the tube right below
his second rib so that he can breathe it
has already been three hours and still
the rescue helicopter has not arrived
while tug is on his way to Mark the
latter asks for water and the soldiers
in a safer location throw bottled water
Ken safely catches the first bottle but
sadly when he tries to catch another he
accidentally steps on a mine causing an
explosion that destroys his foot after a
while tug finally approaches the injured
soldiers and helps Mark before
administering morphine to Ken and
applying a tourniquet to stop the
bleeding from his leg the soldiers are
in need of an immediate rescue but sadly
haven't received any news of an incoming
helicopter or team meanwhile Hale blames
himself for the platoon's tragic
situation mentioning that he is the one
who suggested they investigate the
previous night's incident however his
comrades reassure him that it's not his
fault at all hail then asks smudge to
name his future child if something
happens to him but smudge refuses he
reassures his friend that they will
definitely get out from this deathbed as
time passes no help arrives but the
Third Battalion stays distracted by
talking about their lives and sharing
memories Mark feels thirsty and begins
telling taga's last messages to his
family fiancee and even dog please
search can you tell him that uh
he then mentions that his body is
getting cold and then he cannot hold on
any longer hearing this Pearson and tug
encourage him to hold on but Mark
ignores their words and continues to
share his final messages suddenly they
hear the sound of an approaching Chopper
but the soldiers warned the pilot to
stay away from the Minefield but despite
this the rescue soldiers drop down the
helicopter using harness roofs to help
the injured one and bring everyone to
safety they prioritize the heavily
wounded ones from Pearson to hail and
transform Mark's Body to a stretcher
before loading them onto the helicopter
as the Medics are also present in the
chopper they can now properly treat
their wounds and know their exact
situation sadly Mark doesn't make it and
dies before reaching the hospital and
the injured soldiers also struggle to
survive the movie ends with a
heartwarming message to all the soldiers
who lost their lives in such dangerous
situations while serving in Afghanistan
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching